c'est bien d'entraîner les vieux à
supporter la canicule mais quand même il
y a des limites
que Steven Guillon
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
Stéphane Guillaume
politique trois jours avant le premier
tour Sarkozy lancera l'opération vague
bleue tous ces supporters devront porter
du bleu ça va être spectaculaire des
milliers de Schtroumpfs allant voter
pour Gargamel
au zénith Sarkozy parle d'amour devant
8000 jeunes vivaient aimer espérer ne
vous inclinez jamais quand tu aimes et
que tu es une fille il y a un moment il
faut savoir s'incliner
c'est les 30 ans des grosses têtes dans
quelques jours
c'est de faire plaisir
toujours au zénith François Bayrou s'est
exprimé devant un auditoire conquis de
ce rôle des pelles un regard de sa
montre et les autres sont merde
en revanche quand c'est Ségolène qui
parle l'auditoire se passionne Martine
Aubry SMS Hollande booking de la Noé
guette un pote bloqué dans un couloir de
bus
selon François Bayrou Sarkozy ne peut
même plus entrer en banlieue faux la
semaine dernière il s'est rendu sur la
dalle des Invalides c'est forcément un
quartier super chaud regardez 25 canons
protègent le lieu contre la racaille
Nicolas Hulot n'apportera pas ses voix
Dominique Voynet pourtant elle met du
déodorant Ushuaïa elle a un physique
entièrement bio dégradable c'est injuste
politique internationale George Bush
demande plus de temps pour sa nouvelle
stratégie en Irak 200 000 morts
supplémentaires c'est tout et après
promis on discute
au Cameroun les pygmées sont battus
humiliés déplacés pour les soutenir la
visite de Dieudonné et Jenny Le Pen je
pense qu'il préfère être martyrisé
[Rires]
la Logan cartonne en Irak ici personne
n'en veut elle est trop moche mais
là-bas tu as pas la honte quand tu la
conduite grâce à la burqa personne te
reconnaît
[Applaudissements]
faits divers incendie mortel dans une
maison de retraite une dame était en feu
c'est bien d'entraîner les vieux à
supporter la canicule mais quand même il
y a des limites
pas
[Applaudissements]
un étudiant guinéen tabassé par la
police des frontières sur son t-shirt
des empreintes de chaussures oui ce sont
les nouvelles directives du ministère de
l'Identité nationale pour
identifier un sans-papier tu appuies ta
Rangers sur son estomac
médecine dans le journal Le Monde un
reportage sur le cancer du colon ne
consultez pas pour rien dans six mois
avec les promesses électorales non
tenues on aura tous mal au cul c'est
normal
[Applaudissements]
société selon le journal Le Parisien la
mairie de Paris est motobe c'est exact
tout ce qui est casqué en cuir grosse
botte on n'aime pas Boo
en exclusivité le vélo mise à
disposition des Parisiens regardez le
bien son espérance de vie dans un
couloir de bus et le 150 mètres
[Rires]
présence d'amiante à la
Comédie-Française si on veut se
débarrasser de Mamie c'est peut-être le
moment de lui payer un abonnement
[Rires]
le scoutisme fête ses 100 ans un très
beau bilan 60
000 mises à l'air 30 000 bits aussi rage
et coup de chapeau également à la
bécottard qui lors d'une balade en mer
avait noyé 6 scouts pour la première
fois en France une collection d'animaux
préhistoriques mis en vente un ours des
cavernes un rhinocéros laineux et un
poster géant de régime
à Paris Jean-Paul Gaultier expose ses
vêtements admiraient ce modèle toujours
amusant de s'habiller comme une [ __ ]
les testicules sont au niveau des seins
et on termine par une photo rarissime en
pleine océan un plongeur à retrouver un
spermatozoïde de Guy Carlier
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu